THE WEEKEND, SEE YOU MONDAY.
♪ ♪
>> Sean: WELCOME TO "HANNITY"
LIVE ON THIS BUSY NEWS BREAKING
FRIDAY.
TONIGHT SO MUCH TO COVER,
INCLUDING FORGETFUL JOE’S
SHIFTING RECOLLECTION ON CIVIL
RIGHTS ISSUES.
ALSO WE WILL BRING YOU A HANNITY
HISTORY LESSON ON THE REAL
DEMOCRATIC PARTY AND THE
DISGUSTING HYPOCRISY ON THE
ISSUE OF RACE IN AMERICA.
AND, WE HAVE SHOCKING NEW
FOOTAGE, VIOLENCE AGAINST POLICE
AND THE CHAOS CONTINUES AND ALL
BIG CITIES ACROSS AMERICA.
FIRST, WE TURN TO BREAKING NEWS
OUT OF SEATTLE TONIGHT WHERE
ANARCHY NOW REIGNS SUPREME.
ROADBLOCKS AND CHECKPOINTS,
BORDER WALL’S, ARMED VIGILANTES,
VANDALISM AND EXTORTION.
THIS ISN’T SOME FAILED TO THIRD
WORLD COUNTRY, IT’S A THEME FROM
SEATTLE’S PROMINENT CAPITOL HILL
NEIGHBORHOOD OF JUST A SHORT
DISTANCE FROM THE ICONIC
SPACE NEEDLE.
THE SIX BLOCK AREA IN THE MIDDLE
OF THE CITY HAS NOT BEEN BLOCKED
OFF BY A GROUP OF ALL
SOCIALISTS, REVOLUTIONARY WANT
TO BE IS ARE CALLING THEIR
LITTLE SOCIALIST UTOPIA "THE
CAPITOL HILL AUTONOMOUS ZONE" OR
CHAZ FOR SHORT.
IN THIS LITTLE SLICE OF
SOCIALIST OF HEAVEN, OH POLICE
HAVE BEEN KICKED OUT AND THE
LOCAL POLICE PRECINCT WAS
TOTALLY BANDED BY CITY
OFFICIALS, SUBSEQUENTLY TAKEN
OVER BY THE SO-CALLED PEACEFUL
DEMONSTRATORS WHICH IS PUTTING
EVERYONE INSIDE THE AUTONOMOUS
ZONE AT RISK.
>> THEY HAVE MORE THAN TRIPLED.
AND WE ARE NOT ABLE TO GET TO
IT.
>> ANYONE WITH A FUNCTIONING
BRAIN, YOU HAVE TO KNOW THIS IS
UNACCEPTABLE.
THE MAYOR OF SEATTLE, JENNY
DURKIN IS HER NAME IS EITHER TOO
STUPID OR TOO INCOMPETENT TO
CARE.
SHE’S LETTING THE ANTICHRIST
TAKE OVER AND CONTROL AND EVEN
DESTROY HER CITY.
JUST CALLING THIS AUTONOMOUS
ZONE PATRIOTIC.
LAST NIGHT ON FAKE NEWS CNN SHE
PREDICTED THAT IT WOULD LEAD TO
A SUMMER OF LOVE.
WOW.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> HOW LONG DO YOU THINK SEATTLE
IN THOSE FEW BLOCKS LOOKS LIKE
THIS?
>> I DON’T KNOW, WE COULD HAVE A
SUMMER OF LOVE.
>> I UNDERSTAND YOUR SENTIMENT
MAYOR.
>> WE DON’T HAVE TO SACRIFICE
SAFETY FOR FIRST AMENDMENT
RIGHTS.
BOTH EXIST AND WE WILL MAKE SURE
THAT BOTH EXIST IN SEATTLE.
>> THEY TOOK OVER PARTS OF THE
CITY, THEY TOOK OVER POLICE
PRECINCTS.
SUMMER OF LOVE, ARMED
VIGILANTES, CHECKPOINTS AND
VANDALISM.
OR OF COURSE A COMMUNITY GARDEN.
THE POLICE ARE NOT INVITED.
WHAT DO THEY CALL THAT?
I THOUGHT THAT WAS
DISCONNECTION, THEY EVEN BUILT A
BORDER WALL.
TOUGH ON IMMIGRATION POLICIES.
I THOUGHT LIBERALS WERE AGAINST
THESE THING, AND PRESIDENT TRUMP
NOW VOWING TO RESTORE ORDER, AND
THEY ARE CALLING THIS
INTERVENTION UNCONSTITUTIONAL
AND ILLEGAL.
NOW I WILL SAY THIS.
MY UNSOLICITED HUMBLE ADVICE IS
THIS.
AND, AND THAT WOULD BE FULLY THE
RESPONSIBLE.
THEY CHOOSE, THEY DECLINED THE
PRESIDENT’S OFFER.
MY ATTITUDE AT THIS POINT IS,
AND OTHERWISE I WOULD SAY IT’S
YOU’RE SITTING ON YOUR ESTATE,
HAVE FUN.
WE HAD NO IDEA THAT THIS EVEN
EXISTED.
I DON’T KNOW WHAT’S WORSE, HIM
NOT KNOWING, OR HIM REALLY
KNOWING AND AFRAID TO SAY HE
KNOWS WITH POLITICAL DISCUSSIONS
AND A DRUM CIRCLE IN THE MOB IN
THE MEDIA ARE NOT DOING THEIR
JOB, THIS WAS A CONSERVATIVE
GROUP OF ANY KIND.
AND CONSPIRACY TV, AND CALLING
IT A PEDESTRIAN STREET FAIR.
THEY CALL IT A FESTIVE ZONE WITH
THE FESTIVAL-LIKE ATMOSPHERE.
THUS IT’S A FAR LEFT WHICH WILL
NOW BECOME THE MAINSTREAM OF THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
THEY ARE APPLAUDING THE PEACEFUL
NATURE OF THE DEMONSTRATIONS.
THAT WAS UNTIL THEIR REPORT IN
FAIRNESS TO THEM.
IT WAS JUST AS THEY SAID UNTIL
IT WAS TOTALLY DERAILED BY ONE
OF THE PEACEFUL PROTESTERS IN
THE SUMMER OF LOVE.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> DESPITE THE FACT THAT THIS
ALL BEGAN WITH FORCE, THIS WHAT
YOU ARE SEEING IN FRONT OF ME AS
A PEACEFUL SITUATION.
IN FACT IT SORT OF LOOKS LIKE A
STREET FESTIVAL.
>> THE PRESIDENT MAKES IT LOOK
LIKE THIS AREA WAS TAKEN OVER,
AND IT HAS BEEN RULED BY -- I
DON’T KNOW HOW HE WOULD DESCRIBE
THEM.
>> FOLKS CAN COME AND GO.
>> DO YOU FEEL THE LOVE IN THE
ROOM?
YOU FEEL THE SUMMER OF LOVE IN
THE AUTONOMOUS ZONE, THE
GOVERNOR AND THE DOPEY MAYOR ARE
LETTING THEM TAKE OVER PART OF
THE CITY.
THE NEW YORK TOILET PAPER TIMES
OF COURSE, THEY ARE CALLING THIS
QUOTE.
THEY DON’T ON THIS PROPERTY,
THEY JUST -- THEY NO ONE IS
STOPPING THEM INCLUDING THE
POLICE PRECINCT.
TWO MEMBERS OF THE
AFRICAN-AMERICAN COUNSEL, THEY
WERE PRACTICALLY BOOED OFF
STAGE.
NOW FOR THE SOCIALIST, THE
ANARCHISTS INSIDE OF THE
AUTONOMOUS FREE SUMMER OF LOVE
ZONE, THIS IS NOT ABOUT
REFORMING POLICE.
IT SEEMS LIKE THIS IS THE
SOCIALIST DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
NOW IN THE NEAR TERM, THOSE
TAKING UP RESIDENCE, THE
AUTONOMOUS ZONE, THEY ARE
BEGGING FOR WEAPONS AND
CIGARETTES AND GATORADE.
THIS AUTONOMOUS SUMMER OF PEACE
OWNS IS FILLED WITH ANGRY
SOCIALIST VEGANS, MAYBE BY THE
WAY COMING TO A CITY NEAR YOU.
AT LEAST ONE GOVERNOR IS VOWING
TO MAINTAIN LAW AND ORDER AND
ALL CREDIT GOES OUT TONIGHT TO
SENATOR BILL LEE.
AUTONOMOUS ZONES AND, THEY WANT
EXIST OR BE TOLERATED IN MUSIC
CITY.
THIS COMES AS LAW ENFORCEMENT
OFFICERS AROUND THE COUNTRY,
THEY ARE TARGETED, DEMONIZED AND
IN SIX DISTURBING DAYS.
THE LAWLESS LIBERALS CONTINUE TO
DOUBLE DOWN ON LAWLESSNESS AND
ANARCHY.
AND THEY ARE ALLOWING EVERYONE
TO RUN WILD.
SO, WHO ARE YOU GOING TO CALL
WHEN THERE’S A SERIOUS VIOLENT
CRIME IN MINNEAPOLIS.
THESE ARE THE LAWLESS RADICAL
IDEAS GUESS WHAT, AS SHOTS AT
COPS ALL ACROSS THE COUNTRY AS
THEY ARE BEING HIT WITH BOTTLES